au milieu des explosions
ces militaires Ukrainiens arrêtent une
voiture il faut évacuer en urgence cette
femme blessée ici à Lizy de chance que
les forces ukrainiennes et pro russe
s'affrontent dans une bataille
d'artillerie de plus en plus violente
pour prendre le contrôle de la ville et
de sa jumelle sévero deniersk ou des
centaines de personnes sont retranchées
dans l'usine chimique azote selon les
séparatistes promosco 300 à 400
militaires Ukrainiens seraient à
l'intérieur alors que Kiev parle de 800
personnes bloquées dont des civils
les militaires Ukrainiens les
participants des bataillons
nationalistes restent dans la zone
industrielle à l'usine azote d'où il
bombarde la ville nous ne pouvons pas
agir de manière assez agressive là-bas
car il s'agit d'une installation
d'industrie chimique
samedi le gouverneur régional a déclaré
que le bombardement de l'installation
avait provoqué un incendie et une fuite
de pétrole il s'agit de la dernière zone
importante de l'est de la région de
louansk toujours sous le contrôle
ukrainien dans le sud du pays à Carson
les forces d'occupation promo scout
distribuent des passeports russes aux
habitants des images critiquées par le
président ukrainien
il y a des collaborateurs et des gens de
l'entourage des Russes cela ne ressemble
pas à une file d'attente pour avoir un
passeport mais une tentative pour
obtenir un billet de sortie c'est très
révélateur
selon volodi nerfielenski l'armée
ukrainienne est en train de regagner du
terrain dans la région de Carson et
asaporrija